in the virtual environment we users
often share and upload different
sensitive files and data with each other
for private or professional uses
where we can apply various applications
available on the internet to format our
data in accordance to our requirement
but have we ever wondered if our system
gets hacked by a cyber criminal the
consequences can be drastic
hi guys and welcome to yet another
interesting video by simply learn
but before we begin if you love watching
tech videos
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to never miss an update from
us
let's take a look at the agenda for
today's video
in today's session firstly we'll
understand what is hacking
then understand whether our system is
already hacked or not
then continuing with some counter
measure points regarding how to avoid
getting a system high
and lastly we'll see the demo regarding
if our system is hacked or not
let's begin with what is hacking
as we all know
hacking is an illegal act performed by a
cyber criminal to steal data and
information from the targeted system by
breaking into the system security
unknown to the user
the person who performs this task of
breaking into the system is known as a
hacker
they apply illegal means to gain access
into the targeted system by using
network hacks spam or malicious programs
now that we understand what is hacking
let's take a look at some points to know
whether our system is already hacked or
not
the first point regarding how to check
whether a system is hacked or not
can be cases where the system security
is switched off by unknown means
and it is not visible to the user
this is one of the most primary
checkpoint to know if a system is hacked
or not
next point to check whether a system is
hacked or not
would be
frequent antivirus software failures
which are due to the interference from
hacking attempts performed by a
professional hacker or a cyber criminal
then we also face problems regarding
systems reaction speed which is affected
due to the execution of unknown
applications in the background of the
system
which also affects the hardware
resources in the device
next we also face problems regarding
passwords
which are no longer working or are
changed without a user's intervention
which might indicate that there was some
unknown hacking activity
that took place in our account
let's take a look at some more points
regarding the topic
there are often cases when the system's
cursor move on its own and perform tasks
indicating that the system is being used
by someone else using an illegal hacking
method
there are also cases when we often see
files and folders being created
in the storage disk on the system
which is unknown to us
to better understand the points
regarding how to identify whether our
system is hacked or not let's take a
look
then let's start with the first point
if we want to check whether a system is
hacked or not the first point would be
to choose the settings option
and using privacy and security and
moving on to the windows security
this option that is available on our
system allows us to see various
protection applications that are
available on the system
if we see any problem regarding any one
of them for example
apps and browser control in my system it
says there's a problem with it
which might be due to hacking attempts
that was done on my system
now let's take a look at the other
option how we can check whether a system
is hacked or not
that would be checking the antivirus
software that is installed in a system
if you face problems regarding that
this might be the issue
according to my antivirus software it
says my computer is at risk
this might be due to the interference
from cybercriminal or a hacker while
using different illegal softwares during
its hacking attempt
then there are also cases
where we see there are unknown programs
being executed in the background of our
system
which we can take a look using the task
manager software
using the task manager we can take a
look at each and every application that
is being
executed in the system
and see the origin
if we find any unknown program or
application
we can assume that it might be due to a
hacking attempt
moving on if we want to check further
whether a system is hacked or not
we can check for files or folders that
are being created or known to us for
example this unknown folder
which contains some security details
that are unknown to me
this might be also due to a hiking
attempt by a hacker or a cyber criminal
then there are also cases
when the system's cursor move on its own
and perform tasks that are not initiated
by us and performs copying of different
folders or data from one file to other
this is due to a hiking attempt that was
done on a system and the hacker has
taken control of a system
then there are also cases regarding
login issues or password problem
for example
if i want to access into my account
and there's a problem with the password
it might be
due to
the attempt of hacking into my account
by a professional hacker
seems like there's a problem with the
username
which means there was a hacking attempt
by a professional hacker
we can further check hacking attempts
by accessing our web browser and
checking whether there is some
extra add-ons or unknown add-ons that
wasn't installed by us
this might also indicate a hacking
attempt on the system
now that we are clear about how to check
whether a system is hacked or not let's
take a look at some of the counter
measure against hacking
let's begin
the first point regarding how to avoid
hacking is do regular manual security
checks and keep the system security
updated
using certified antivirus softwares is a
basic counter measure against hacking
attempts
and if possible visit only secure
websites for surfing on the internet or
use vpn or other internet security
applications to mask your system's
network to avoid any hacking attempts
for the device
then we have avoid clicking on random
web popups and ads to avoid hackers from
getting into a system and accessing a
device data
and lastly use strong passwords or
complex passwords for your login details
applying these counter measures we can
avoid hacking to a certain extent
with this we have reached the end of the
video
if you have any questions regarding the
topic you can ask them in the comment
section
thank you for watching
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here